pour la liberté d'opinion en france
demandé la fin
la cause du peuple en est la cause du
crash
demandez-le à cause du patron paul est
saisie arbitraire mission trouver la
cause du peu
suivre la première procédure diffuser la
cause du peuple et bien vous voyez le
sun un journal qui n'est pas interdite
car le président de la 17e chambre
correctionnelle refusé d'interdire qui
n'a rien de ce qu'on a lu pour le
gouvernement puisqu'ils ne lis même pas
avant d'interdire soute est soi disant
pour reconstituer une ligue que nous
nous n'avons jamais constitué non nous
ne faisons pas partie à l'ingestion
arrêté est ce que vous considérez comme
le nouveau leader de la gauche pour
l'état je ne fais pas partie de la
gauche prolétarienne je n'en ai jamais
fait partie j'ai pris la direction la
cause du peuple parce que je voulais
exprimer ma solidarité avec tout ce
qu'on a mis en prison au nom d'un délit
d'opinion signification donnez-vous à
votre arrestation aujourd'hui bien je ne
peux pas bouger actuellement que je suis
je vous dirai plus tard ce qui ce qui
s'ensuivra